hey folks please enjoy this clip from
our show which you can find every single
day at 400 p.m. Eastern exclusively on
Rumble we've been doing the best shows
we've ever done completely free of
censorship and on a platform that
actually supports us you can also
support us on locals where you can
access a ton of exclusive content movie
riffs as well as an archive of over a
thousand full episodes going back as far
as 7 years we've also teamed up with
merch engine to bring you a new lineup
of really awesome quality shirts hoodies
and now even hats so come check out our
untethered uncensored show on Rumble
every single weekday at 400 p.m. Eastern
you stupid
idiots tonight to rajie P Henson's
brutally honest and emotional
explanation of Hollywood's pay disparity
is going viral CNN host Gail King
interviewed Henson oh good it's Gail
King and the cast of The Color Purple
it's a film from CNN parent company
Warner Brothers Discovery oh okay so
this is what was it called vertical
integration
this is what you call in the industry
vertical integration where you have a
new site cover something innocuous about
a movie that they're making to promote
the
movie great great
business now King asked Henson if she
was thinking by the way let me just let
me speedrun this to you because there's
a lot of talking we we'll play some of
the talking but I just want to give you
the the breakdown she said she was in a
movie with Brad Pit she said she got
paid $150,000 and Brad P got paid $10
million and that's because no one knows
who the [__] you are and he's Brad Pit
no one no one went to go see whatever
movie that was because taji P Henson was
in it no about quitting acting quit it
then quit then quit quit it's a hard job
goe an only FY sorry you're still making
millions a year but what it's not 10
million whenever actors cry poverty I
want to slap them right on their
face you I only got paid
$150,000 for one
gig she's
crying yeah oh maybe you're not getting
rolls anymore cuz you're fat now too did
you think about that that's probably
part of it too
huh but you guys aren of the mother from
the The Karate Kid the Jaden Smith
Karate Kid no I never watched that one
Frozen because I was not going to ruin
the Legacy be now The Next Karate kit
that I'll watch um look all the way to
the left what is that guy wearing and
may I ask why are you
gay what is that
outfit oh it's uh the farmsworth Bentley
I didn't know zubas made entire suits
yes tired of
working you got tired of playing pretend
with other people for millions of
dollars it must be
exhausting so hard you know what you're
not working at the gym you're fat now
yeah yeah fatty fat ugly and
old being great you know why Brad Pit
still gets rolles he still has abs yeah
honestly you want to know why Tom Cruz
still gets rols he works out and stays
in shape they're also good at what they
do they're also good at their job is at
what I do getting paid a fraction of the
cost yeah CU you were never in Fight
Club thank you but for real it's very
easy you weren't in you weren in Oceans
11 [__] what do you want [__] great
Point get over yourself you know but but
guys she was part of the Think Like a
Man franchise I don't know what that is
I don't know what that is cuz this then
she wasn't she's not doing very well
because if she was thinking like a man
she wouldn't be crying right now be
happy to have a job this would be like
if we went on a podcast it like pays its
guests and then we're like wait a minute
so let me get this straight they paid to
Alex Stein and Ryan long more than us
but that's kind of [__] really that
is sort of [__] bro come on man
tired I he people exact amount as them
no that's also looking at whatever
Russell br's Rumble deal is and being
like yeah yeah we should be getting the
exact down of the penny W really
really we have to the math ain't math we
should have done that when we
renegotiated our deal we should have
written down like an insane number on a
piece of paper and slid it over to
Chris like we want 45 just write 45
Grand per month like on a piece of paper
slide it across the table and go I think
find our offer reasonable plus
incidentals and then they just laugh us
out of the building right we can still
hear them laughing as we're getting into
our cars inside the building
yeah here to discuss this with me now is
the chick for the mo the woman used to
be fat that's now skinny from Community
oh oh hey that's that chick from that
Brad Pit movie see that's how that works
man yeah that's how it goes that's why
he gets paid more EV that that has
really touched a nerve in Hollywood uh
she's been taji has been nominated for
an Oscar she's yeah she win one one did
she win an
Oscar no I'm pretty sure Brad Pit has
several okay but you're crying about
this right but then if here's the thing
it's supply and demand right you just
made the color purple you should know
how selling people works here's how
here's how it is they don't need if you
go I want make $10 million they go
that's okay we'll get another chick that
means you weren't you weren't worth it
you're not going to make the money right
yeah when Brad pickles I won $10 million
to go that's it and they pay it can I
point something out too this woman has
been nominated for an Oscar Brad Pit has
two one two of them let's not even count
nominations then too because we really
want to break it down he also has two
Golden Globe Awards and two British
Academy film Awards cool cool cool
uh had multiple Emmys Screen Actor Guild
Awards Emmys aren't real Emmys don't
count for anything Emmy are you know
what's funny you know who else has an
Emmy Brad Pit I just didn't count it
because nobody counts those I'm not
kidding I believe you he has a prime
time Emmy too I just didn't count it
because nobody cares it must be a racist
thing except Denzel Washington also gets
10 million a movie so it's not a racial
thing could it be that you're a bad
actress is that is that a possibility
she's a household name no she's not what
household maybe households in Atlant
incomplete households MCH we found
something we found something on
tuby that is going to blow your mind
there are these movies that are made
okay and actually we could actually
Segway into right now there's these
movies made on tuby right that are P
specifically
specifically made by uh made by black
made by you know black families and
black people in Atlanta right and
they're on tub so they got made the add
to play now but I need to show you what
things what movies they release these
are homemade black these are homemade
black directors and acted
movies and when I say that it makes the
room look like it should win an Oscar
that's what you're about to see so
there's a commercial running now it's
obvious it's on tuby so so commercial's
almost over I just wanted to show you
that they're making money on these cu
the commercial is running okay let me
introduce you to a movie called what was
this one called gangster's
daughter
yes Fiverr Intro by the way this is very
much of fi in we're going to be skipping
we're going to be skip there it is
Sullivan production hold
on it's got a lion it did the growl it
did the growl like
MGM they're going to get sued for that
here you go get ready this is this is a
movie you could watch on tuby right
now I'll skip around but you just have I
needed to show you this MCH that's not
real open the [__]
[Music]
safe this is
what that blood effect was so funny
clear 1 2
3 what is it this is so bad oh oh you
have no
idea you haven't even seen the romance
scenes did they make this whole movie on
Fiverr here you
go I haven't touched the audio by the
way what that was them I haven't touched
the audio that's how it
sounds what is this I forget there's a
specific name for these movies um he had
it before [__] yeah yeah
bro who knows all I know is this was
made by black churches yeah so black
churches make these okay so okay why hey
hey you go let me let me talk to you for
a
sec what's up
daddy know I've been worried about you
oh my God this is I you've been
stressing
out this is bad being away from home and
then and there's a scene here that I'm
going to show you you got to figure it
out so M how many have you worked with
one of those with people oh the white
guy is the bad guy h no no no the black
guys are also bad guys here
watch so by the way hey black people
maybe don't cast other black people to
be rapists and criminals mov
comination what is this said open the
[__]
saish no no why did you hit my sister
shut the [__] up before you next m
effect turn around put your face against
the
wall
okay oh it gets dark it gets real dark
oh it's very dark already my father's
bodyguard he went to the
store please hurry up and come
back please
hurry killed her
[Music]
sister okay
wow I don't care open the
[__] oh no it gets better it's a
little more you just got to really see
now oh my God no he rapes her yep he
rapes her why are you looking away but
this is how rape this is how rape looks
like look at this look at the rape moves
look at the rape
moves oh [__] why did you turn into the
rape
[__] [__] and and and that's why you
don't get paid the same that's an eye
poke that's illegal that's how you don't
get paid the same God I need to know the
name of this movie what a [__] movie
It's called gangster's daughter but it's
all if you like gangster's daughter
you'll also like suffocated here let me
just show you the just you look at the
actual titles of these movies look at
these just to please a woman nasty these
these entire genre of these kind of
movies safe word the bargain a good man
Cutthroat only fan hot girl these are
all the same type of movies and it's
just like it does seem like me black
mega churches right they fund these
movies and they make them and I think
99% of them are made in
Atlanta oh I bet uhhuh that makes sense
99% of them are made in Atlanta all
right uh let's see here oh where were we
yes that's right sorry getting back to
it's surprising to a lot of people to
see those tears and to hear her say
she's not being paid
fairly what's her net worth I'm going to
look it up I want to see CU I want
because remember poor people I want to
see because she must be poor right taji
P Henson it's already autofilling net
worth because people $12
million she's $12 million in the bank
and she's bitching she's crying about
crying
poverty yeah I mean the truth is none of
us are you know the pay disparity for uh
black women period is horrible and it
extends to Hollywood as well well yeah
because again and I again I just that's
how it works though right that's how it
works because and I man I'm going to
blow people's minds right now I really
think you're ready it's going to blow
your minds the thing is is say since you
guys always want to be casted as
powerful empowered black women you know
that whole like I'm an empowered black
woman the problem is when you have women
writers now they don't know how to make
those correctly so you come across as
sassy
[__] and that's why nobody wants to
watch these movies because whenever you
go to watch a movie when and be honest
let's be honest when you see somebody
like tajari P Hensen or what was that
the woman king or or the the [__] who
played Obama whenever you any see them
doing watching one of those movies
you're 100% going to go into a movie
where they're going to talk down to
white people say they're super empowered
and and and blame white people for
everything so yeah the people don't want
to go [__] be talked down to by a
black woman that's why they rather go
see Tom Cruz jump out of an airplane
it's way more fun isn't it it's so cool
he's so much more fun he's they rather
see John Wick shooting bad guys now they
killed his dog yeah he can connect with
a story like that I know yeah and you
guys are fighting dogs that's what's
happening no but and that's the point
it's like you guys have empowered
yourself into the [__] lowest pay
rate in Hollywood it's not because
people are racist it's because they're
forcing you they perfect example with it
did with a Little Mermaid you force the
black girl into a white redheaded role
and then people resent that not because
she's black but because they grew up
with a cartoon so then they're [__]
mad they're [__] mad at you you are
making yourselves hated stop acting this
way be likable be approachable and I'm
going to say this to all women have you
tried smiling you're prettier when you
smile I do like that you just I I do
like that you went with the Mel Gibson
stop being that please stop being that
please
stop that's why that's why there's
certain actors and you see oh I love
that guy I watch here's a perf perfect
example man there there's Tim if Tim
Robinson is in something I'm like I'll
give it a shot he's likable he's not
going to talk down to me he's not going
to make me feel you know dumb and he's
he'll be the dumb one I don't care or or
or like like John like [__] you know
Keo re is another boy he's goingon to do
his [__] movie he's going to do kung
fu and shoot people and I'm going to go
watch it he's going to do kung fu and
shoot people yeah and that sounds great
that sounds great but if I go watch a
movie with tajari P Henson you're going
to tell me like white people are the
reason that you can't hear the smoke
that protector and like I don't want to
do
that nobody wants to sit through that
nobody in the world wants to be talked
down
to that's the reason and that's the
reason why notice you said black women
cuz black men are getting paid the same
or they are they're getting paid the
same so it's the this what happened was
they wish it was also black men that
weren't getting paid the same so they
could turn it racist but it's not racist
denel Washington commands the same
amount of money as Brad pittas in a
movie you know what I mean cuz he's a
good The Rock exists yeah the
rock you know I'd still rather watch the
rock and all his movies are terrible
Michael B Jordan makes a shitload of
money you don't because you're annoying
stop being
annoying [__] Christ black women
can't even play that's the other thing
white women make money because white
women at least will still play the
Damsel in Distress you hoes you ever
seen a black girl play a damsel in
distress I have it I can't think of one
no they're always
strong independent women the last Dan
the last Danel distress I saw was Tyler
Perry playing
media still a
dude does it hurt your feelings black
women that other black women would
rather go watch a black guy in drag play
media than go watch tari P Hensen that's
got to suck you got to know how annoying
you are it's so [__]
annoying what broke my heart about
seeing it is that teraji is one of our
Treasures to whom wait what to
whom what has she made that's worth a
[__] I'm I'm going to look I'm going
look at her movies being a hooker in
Hustle and
Flow okay she was in the new color
purple she was in Muppets Haunted
Mansion she was in
minions rise of grew she was in what men
want she was in the best of enemy are
are these movies ringing a bell with
anybody no she was in what men want as
the [__]
opposite as an example of what they
don't she was also in Proud Mary hidden
figures oh she was in that space movie
where black women got us to space uh she
was in ice AG the great ex
excapade she was in no good deeds I'm
really trying to see here
talk to me now okay those are her movies
let's go Brad Pit movies I really want
to compare these no no we're gonna do
this Brad Pit movies you ready Fight
Club uh let's see let's Okay snatch
Moneyball Benjamin
Button the assassination Mr and Mrs
Smith Babel all the oceans
movies Meo black Interview with a
Vampire Legends of the Fall
seven [__] is so famous if you went
to like forign like if you went to Japan
and you were like name a Hollywood actor
they would go Brad Pit M no that's true
that or Tom Cruz like royon those two
and if you think it's just because BR
Brad Pit was attractive he played a
[__] dork in the big short and he was
great in that
too [__] he was really great in The
Big Short yeah so what are you talking
about no you just make shitty movies why
would you think you've ever earned the
same amount compare box
offices God [__] whiny [__] you
know what I mean she's one of the ones
that has been in the trenches for
forever she should be paid what she's
worth and the tears that she she is
being paid what she's worth you just
don't like what she's worth right the
problem is you're not happy with the
agreed upon price I got it but look
these numbers are coming straight from
Carfax there's nothing I could do about
it you know did I'm sorry but this is
this is Kelly Kelly Bluebook Value I
don't know what to tell you that's what
it is you know and honestly it's not
even a woman thing because like Scarlett
Johansson when they found out she got
ripped off everybody was outraged of
course you have very good point that's
it's not even a woman thing when Disney
[__] her over like even guys were
going hey uh your franchise is pretty
much [__] in its dying breath and
that [__] is about all you got left
very so you might as well pay her her
[__]
money just stop you're doing it to
yourselves you're making these Niche
movies that are only for black women
that's why you're not getting the money
you're not making box office movies for
everybody to watch nobody wants to watch
guilt porn hey so I I found some neat
little articles sure uh Brad Pitt's 18
most successful films ranked by box
office and I got the same article from
the same place for teraji so Burn After
Reading made 163 million uh [__] 12
Monkeys 168 [__] 12 Years a Slave how
about this how about this how about this
what's his lowest 160 whatever million
give me 18 what's the lowest on the list
163 you said yeah 163 okay give me her
top uh her top mhm oh it was The Curious
Case of vamin button at 335 million the
movie oh my God
Ry you couldn't have written that any
better that was we had no idea going
into this you couldn't have written that
any better that is so [__]
funny holy [__] that might be one of the
funniest things that's ever organically
happened on this show wow wow
oh my
God pretty sure the math is mathing now
now the math is mathing isn't
it give me number two
Virgie oh hold if it's another rad pit
movie I'm gon lose my goddamn
mind oh no it's date night with Steve
Corell all Brad Pitt's movies are
[__] they made
how much did how much did date night
make prob good money 152 mil it still
made less than Brad Pit's lowest oh
sorry my bad the her next down the list
was hidden figures at 236 there you go
something yeah Summers uh what's the
number one what Brad Pit's number one
Brad Pit's number one oh Brad Pit's
number one oh God just want to compare
these two things it's a lot of scrolling
it's a lot of movies it's a lot of
movies holy [__] bro his number one
World War Z 540 million that is why you
make less
money that is why you make usess
money her number one movie was Benjamin
bu that's so [__] funny to
me the number one
movie [__] just for her because each of
us that are further along in our careers
we're trying to leave the door open for
every black actress is coming up behind
us and the fear that she had and the
despair that she had was that she is not
making enough to be able to tell them
what they should be asking for and she
knows that if it's hard for her it's
even harder for them so it just it broke
my heart and I think that's why
everybody's been responding and and
chiming in and making okay person who
hasn't done anything after
Community
like sounds good what are you doing
that's not Mindy King wait wait the The
Walking Dead after shows don't count oh
sorry I got the show wrong it's all the
same thing she knows that we love her
and we support her and that we're
walking the same path with her yeah I
want to play a little bit to what you
were talking about why here about what
she said in a separate
interview where's my yo fat tits maybe
that's why you ain't making money you
look like That's So
Raven oh God yeah raise I haven't I
haven't seen a raise in my income since
Proud Mary cuz you've been making
[__] animated movies and voiceover
work you got to sit in your pajamas and
do voiceover work maybe if you're not
this is something women are always
incapable of realizing but maybe just
maybe if you've always been making the
same money maybe it's not that you're
underpaid maybe it's that you've been
being overpaid this whole time yeah yeah
and then then you're [__] then you're
shitty acting adjusted for
inflation which by the way you need to
adjust for
inflation and you know you know what's
going to make Studios want to hire her
more bitching about her pay all the time
bitching about her pay all the time is
going to really make people because
instead they'll just be like here's the
thing and that's and that's something
that's not that you're never going to be
able to quantify because they just not
going to hire you she not even going to
get the opportunity anymore because
they'll be like do we want to hire her
do we want to hire what what was who's
the one from [__] the one that does
all the movies now from Avatar and
Guardians of the Galaxy Khloe zelana or
whatever her name is oh zo zo Z Zoe Zana
her they'll just hire her because she
doesn't [__] about the way she gets
paid she just [__] probably gets paid
more than you she's a better actress but
you know and stay and honestly is hot
and stayed in shape so I almost had to
walk away from col you haven't walked
away of anything especially a buffet you
fat [__] shut the [__]
up because you know what tell me tell me
tell me Queen tell me Queen if I don't
take a stand how am I making it easy for
Fantasia and Danielle and Al and and and
Fel I know any of those people Hal Berry
and bye
Felicia she's comparing herself to Hal
Berry you're you're no h Berry
okay then what why why am I doing this
if it's all just for me what the why are
you here but it is for you cuz it's
about you're the one saying you're
getting underpaid yeah you're not
bitching about their pay you're not
bitching about their you you how do you
even know how much they make you dumb
[__] be so funny if one of these
[__] came out and was just like yeah
I'm fine
yeah yeah I'm sure you you experienced a
lot of hardship going to North Carolina
State University you dumb
idiot pay in any industry in some ways
is very subjective I I can only imagine
in Hollywood it's
even she was born in 1970 in southeast
Washington DC the daughter of Bernice NE
Gordon a corporate manager at Woodward
and lur oh my God she came from
money of course they all all these
Hollywood people are [__] spoiled oh
you know what this
is this is this is her projecting all
the [__] she gets from her family
because she don't make [__] in [__]
Hollywood I she doesn't make [__]
compared to her successful family hey
maybe the re maybe the reason your pay
has stayed the same is because you're
not going to give you a pay raise when
you used to look like this and now you
look like that is that maybe part of the
reason do you think
maybe she didn't even really look that
good to begin with no but at least she
was in shape is is she was a
shape more so what do you think is the
reason that you know Hollywood
Executives get away you can't say it's
racism you can't say it's
racism it was paying someone like Taraji
less and not giving her a raise movie to
movie rooll to roll because it's
different companies and they're
different production things because you
don't get you don't get eras because
you're doing a bunch of movies if that
was the [__] case I know a lot of
beist actors have made hundreds of
sci-fi movies that are making 50 Grand
of
film Jesus Christ there's a re here
honey there's there's a reason that
Denzel Washington's net worth is 300
million million dollar and yours is 12
okay there's a reason you want to know
why Denzel Washington and he and by the
way never cries racism Denzel
Washington's never cried
racism uh maybe because he made training
day and Man on Fire did you think about
that or maybe Remember the Titans or
American Gangster or Malcolm [__]
X can you name a bad film from him all
his equalizer movies are good too I like
it black John Wick is
awesome it is it's what it is but it's
cool uh broken Glazer okay I did work
all right thank you sir we'll check that
out uh DOTA run and wild Henson is dumb
it doesn't matter how woke Hollywood is
no one is going to work with loud angry
black women Merry Christmas thank you
Lord Pepsi merry 20 bucks Merry
Christmas to all of you and a Happy New
Year thank you zanzan thank you thank
you first one was for daywave this one's
for ROTC thank you
Sansan
well you know systemic racism is a part
of
every what's the matter what is systemic
racism man that's again it would make
sense if black male actors were making
money though but they are but they are
though everything that happens in this
nation but and this is hey evat here's
the reason people don't go watch movies
because then they go watch a movie with
a black actress and the black actress's
entire monologue is about systemic race
racism maybe people don't want to watch
movies to feel
guilty it maybe it's possible maybe it's
supposed to be escapism and we're
supposed to be having fun yeah maybe we
would want to go sit down and have be
lectured by by a black woman who makes
more money than you imagine that can you
[__] imagine you're a goddamn metal
worker or some [__] and you're [__]
coming home you're making 60,000 a year
if you're lucky right all right 60,000 a
year you got three kids you're coming
home every day and she's like I'm only
making $12
million why would you go watch that
person's movie I wouldn't like what at
what point
why yeah this woman is a miserable
[__] and by the way hidden figures the
only hidden figures that got us to space
is SWAT
stickers that's where their term moon
cricket comes from there's this thing
where they pit people against each other
where the idea is well you know if you
don't want to do it we'll get somebody
else to do it and that's a yeah that's
how that's how the that's how the job
market
works I'm sorry are you telling that you
want an upand cominging actress who's
going to get an great opportunity to
stand tall and not take a role because
tajari P Hensen said no yeah hey hey
ma'am if if I were a producer and I said
you know what I need this movie to be a
hit get me Brad Pit and I sat down with
Brad Pit and Brad Pit said I want a $100
million I'd go [__] you I'll get
somebody else to do it Matt Damon it
works the same way for other people too
if you if you ask for more than your
worth I call Matt Damon and he'll do it
you know what I mean I'll get someone
else that'll trust me that'll do it you
think Brad Pit's never had this happen
before where they're like well [__] it
that's too much and be like okay cool
Brad I'll get Ryan Gosling it's really
not a big deal you're very
interchangeable at this point people
love that guy anyway he's a young you
now he's the new you so we just get him
you know Ryan Gosling does rule he
fucking's awesome of course he's one of
those rare dudes where it's like like
like women love them but guys also love
them yeah his rent may be due and so
they may take the lesser amount and and
we are we are so what you want is the
the woman whose rent is due who's
getting a film opportunity you want them
to say no and stand up for a woman who
has a lot more money and is saying no to
the
role yeah is that what you're saying
that's about uh what it sounds because
that that sounds like what you're
saying as a as a as a industry because
we don't get to have the Brilliance of
someone as taji because they don't want
to pay them what Brilliance of what
doing a voice in
Gru they worth and it's a fight that you
know white actors don't have and white
female actors don't have and what she
said that really resonated with me AB no
no no no no no no why female actresses
also have that fight I'm going to use
Mar I'm just going to use your same
example if I wanted to make a movie I'm
like I got to have Scarlett Johansson in
this movie and she would have go I want
$100 million I'd be like [__] you
there's somebody younger and hotter
that's okay Anna De armos will do it for
20 million it's fine not a big deal
we'll find somebody else I'll get that
Rachel Zigler at a discount thank you
nobody wants to hire her right now Bri
Arsenal do it for a
sandwich she needs one [__]
cryo [__] out it you crazy was when
she said even if she fights and gets
what she needs for this particular film
she has to start all over again the next
time she gets a film yeah
that's how Hollywood works oh my God she
just descri how all this stuff works
holy [__] oh my
God yeah because you don't get to walk
in and say well I negotiated this this
and this and I am to rajie P Henson and
I have this Oscar nomination whatever no
you're it's like you're start over Nom
you we're gonna give you this $5 in a
folding chair it's it's the same for all
of us and it's infuriating and
exhausting
one of the factors here the purple she
just said In that clip she almost walked
away let me show you what a real actor
does okay because this is this is
starting a bug let me show let me let me
just real quick show you what a real
actor
does here the nudity in the film was
that scary for you as an actor to do
well the script called for it was an
important part of detective crash's
Journey what are we 10 years old I've
seen every [__] on the
planet I've seen everyone n naked so
you've seen everyone naked yeah see if
they got tattoos they do they get no
gift if you get a tattoo you don't get
anything for Christmas not that year you
think getting a tattoo is good no
getting a tattoo is not good I don't
care about it but it's not good
behavior that's a real actor
[__] F in the chat H did he die yeah
he did I thought he just was sick I
don't know he died well if you knew he
was sick well I couldn't even do the job
I couldn't even I had to flip that I had
to flip that format around yeah we
really we worked that Norm joke it was
pretty good I like
that from that film that's a film that
is near and dear to the heart of Oprah
Winfrey who's a part of the that process
yeah it's near and dear to her heart
because she's the executive producer and
if no one watches it the whole thing
goes
dark which is a funny thing to say about
The Color
Purple cuz they're black come on the
joke was already
there they got it by
context God damn
it does it surprise you to hear uh that
even on a film like that where there is
a prominent black woman as a part of the
process of making it that she could
still feel wait a second hold on hold on
I'm hold on hold on hold on Oprah is the
executive
producer of the new C color purple film
right and she's complaining that she's
not getting paid enough on the new color
purple film pick that up with Oprah do
you know who could fix that problem
Oprah Oprah who has more M by the way
another example of a black woman who
didn't make it yeah this [__] she got
held down real bad maybe by Gil cuz she
liked
[Laughter]
it
that she was underpaid to Raji we're
showing here posted a photo of Oprah
thanking her double sunburn Oprah still
a thousand Hawaiian children with a rock
[__] that
[__] for supporting her throughout her
career but what do you make of that EV
that well well we don't know if if Oprah
had anything to do with the pay
situation she is the
[Music]
executive
producer that means she's the boss
boss if the let me explain something to
you if the owner of Home Depot walked
into one of these stores that says we're
giving everybody a raise you give him a
raise cuz he's the owner of Home
Depot so we can't say that she was
Waring against anything that Oprah did
in particular so I want to make sure I
say that um because honestly like making
fun of Oprah when you're a black actress
you don't want to do that cuz that'll
ruin your entire career here that's
essentially a death sense yeah you don't
you don't want why don't why don't you
think you hear about Stacy Dash no more
oh my
God poor Stacy Dash I know um she fell
off hard she can still get it though oh
yeah she lives up in Pasco yeah now
she's Stacy door Dash that's what she
does for a
[Laughter]
living good night folks I think we're
done I think that's good enough St door
Dash that's how we're ending we go with
that merry Christmas everybody